nous donnerons bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
concrètement quel était le projet de
l'oscd remettre l'équité fiscale
je dirais que on a depuis assez
longtemps une opposition entre les états
d'un côté et un contexte plus
internationales de l'autre avec des
taxes gafa nationale qui sont prises ou
contente de prendre
et puis bien évidemment on a des grandes
entreprises sur une activité qui est
largement dématérialisé donc ça pose
toute une série de questions toute une
série de difficultés
et donc comme souvent c'est mieux
d'aborder ces questions à un niveau qui
est un niveau international que ce soit
pour que ce soit plus efficace que ce
soit plus équitable et puis aussi pour
que les choses soient faites clairement
y compris pour ces entreprises qui
doivent pouvoir exercer leurs activités
normalement et puis il faut penser aussi
que c'est une activité qui va se
développer toujours plus parce que ses
gaffes à louga femmes
en réalité c'est l'activité économique
et la crise actuelle du coronavirus va
le montrer toujours plus or on va
toujours plus avoir de numérique
toujours plus avoir de dématérialisation
donc il faut que la fiscalité sans être
punitive s'adapte à ses activités pour
qu'encore une fois on évite des effets
d'aubaine qu'on évite que ce que un état
vous impose dès qu'on puisse y déroger
en allant dans un autre état donc voilà
c'est c'est des discussions qui sont en
cours dont on comprend que elles vont
être repoussée du fait du contexte
actuel mais le contexte actuel du
coronavirus encore une fois rend
vraiment beaucoup plus prévenants ce
débat alors lancé des oeufs a pour
objectif de présenter un accord
politique à 137 pays à la mi-octobre
est-ce possible ce avant le salon vous
c'est difficile de faire des deux de
faire des prédictions ce domaine mais ce
qui est certain c'est que il
faut qu'on arrive à mettre à plat ces
questions parce que il faut qu'on ait
une fiscalité qui soit à la fois moderne
et à la fois efficaces mais en même
temps bien sûr qu'ils préservent je
crois que c'est extrêmement important
l'activité des entreprises y compris les
activités de ces entreprises mais
j'insiste bien là dessus c'est que on a
ciblé ses grandes entreprises parce que
ce sont les plus visibles mais il n'y a
pas qu'elle est et la crise actuelle va
voir toute une partie de notre économie
est finalement vers les secteurs
d'activité qui sont aujourd'hui ce dégât
femmes et donc c'est important de ne pas
non plus faire des taxes pour viser une
entreprise particulière il faut repenser
mais ça c'est pas quelque chose qui nous
il faut repenser à la fois notre droit
et notre fiscalité est encore une fois
le contexte actuel du coronavirus on
rend vraiment aujourd'hui très important
d'avoir à la fois un droit et une
fiscalité qui soient des mécanismes qui
est notre économie à s'en sortir dans la
crise actuelle et la crise qui louent
leur dernière question voit bien
aujourd'hui il ya une transition
beaucoup plus rapide vers le numérique
les vieux modèles économiques souffrent
tout est sur internet aujourd'hui
finalement les grands gagnants de cette
crise sanitaire se sont nés à gaza on a
vu on voit que les gars faron des
résultats trimestriels qui sont bons on
a parlé de leurs résignant se voir du
fait qu'il bénéficiait de la crise
actuelle c'est à la fois normal il avait
investi énormément dans cette économie
du futur qui n'est plus du futur métier
du présent c'est normal qu'ils en
profitent mais il faut maintenant que on
a bien sûr des activités qui ne peuvent
pas se déplacer vers un modèle internet
vers un modèle dématérialisée mais il
faut que
toute notre économie elle le peut quand
elle le doit se repenser et précisément
on peut aussi prendre modèle sur les
gaffes à un certain nombre de bruno nom
des ronds merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat associé ainsi que
professeur de droit des sociétés à la
sorbonne bon